let's take Close Encounters of the Third
Kind and end Star Wars
let's say they both came out around the
same time why did one have a longer
shelf-life and the other one is just
this amazing nostalgic film that those
of us at that time remember fondly it's
fascinating to look at that case study
because yeah you have two films that had
similar budgets both had similar type of
filmmakers they were targeting a very
similar audience they're released at the
same time like everything is the same
one becomes a really good movie that
people love and actually is it pretty
well close to calendars in the Third
Kind another becomes a fifty billion
dollar brand and so what there's a
variable in there somewhere that created
that separation in the marketplace and
week weekend we can look at that and
probably guess pretty closely why that
happened there's a book that I read
recently called how Star Wars conquered
the universe where they asked Steven
Spielberg this exact same question and
because him and him and Lucas would
actually give each other producer points
on the on all of their movies and so so
Lucas had producer points on Close
Encounters Spielberg had producer points
on Star Wars obviously Spielberg got a
better part of that deal but and they
said well why you know why did it work
out so well for Lucas and you know
pretty well for you but it's not even in
the same ballpark
he said there's two reasons he said from
the beginning Lucas approached this
project not as just a single film he
always had a broader vision he
understood that there was story before
this there's gonna be story after this
maybe he didn't have all the things
planned out exactly and have it all
worked out but his vision was very big
from the beginning and secondly he said
he had a world that people wanted to
explore hey the story world he said I
never even gave any thought of my story
world the the setting of Close
Encounters our world that's just being
invaded by aliens but what he did he
created a world that people wanted to
continue to explore and and and if you
can create a world in an IP and
intellectual property that people want
to continue to explore
then all of a sudden that then makes the
room for the other things that you want
to do and so you know what's really
interesting about Lucas in the same book
is that he didn't grow up wanting to be
a filmmaker he wanted he grew up wanting
to be an architect and he worked at his
dad's toy store every summer as a kid
and so he approached filmmaking not from
the filmmaking standpoint he has
approached it from a architectural and
toy standpoint and and and he still went
in to make a good movie of course but he
then approached it that the industry and
the creative and the writing of it in a
completely different way that then
fueled all these opportunities if you
look at from the original Star Wars
movie the the cantina scene where Luke
and obi-wan they go into the cantina and
there's all those crazy aliens around
and they this is where they find Han
Solo for the first time there was there
was a very specific choice of I want
these crazy aliens all around they could
have had to cut back on budget they
could have had everybody look human like
Luke if they wanted to but instead he
really made sure that every single
character in that bar and in that
cantina looked had a very distinctive
look that they they seem mysterious that
they it was obvious that all of them had
some sort of backstory involved and just
that creative one the writing decision
to the direct oral decision if you watch
the scene the way they made sure they
got shots of all of them there were
interesting ones in the foreground in
the background they took time in the in
the edit of the film to cut cut cut and
show a handful of them then those
creative opportunities both on the
writing the directing and the editing
then fuelled short stories and video
games and cartoons that dealt with all
of them they created web content for all
of them they created game content for
all of them and they created toys for
all of them so now all of a sudden where
most filmmakers and directors would say
my scene is about my protagonist and my
antagonist and the character our sense
characters everything else is background
Lucas never considered anybody
background he looked at all these other
characters as potential stories
potential stories potential stories that
just so happened to be in the background
of this scene but I'm gonna develop all
of them as if they could be the heroes
of their own story and then put them in
the background so so now the creative
mindset is different when he approaches
a story so how do we do that as
independent filmmakers from $100,000
feature well all of a sudden the
roommate of your protagonist now that's
just in the background on a few
different scenes now you should take the
time to think how do I make that guy
interesting or that girl interesting how
do I give them an interesting look or an
interesting backstory how do I make them
if how could I make them the
protagonists of their own story I'm
going to develop them as if there they
could be and then I'll go back and put
them in the background now when I
approach my short film this really
interesting weird eclectic characters
now in there that could then spur a
whole companion novel maybe it's a EP of
music maybe it's a sole social media
account for this crazy character is
tweeting back and forth elite leading up
or after the film there's lots of
different things using the principles
that you see from Lucas and now applying
that into your your specific smaller
project
you